May thy servant Camilla who wears this
Crown be filled by thine abundant grace
and with all princely virtues
reign in her heart O King Of Love there
being certain of thy protection she may
be crowned with thy gracious favor
through Jesus Christ Our Lord
amen
the Queen's scepter and Rod are brought
from the altar
by the right Reverend and right
honorable Lord chartres
and the right Reverend Rose Hudson
Wilkin Bishop of David receive the Royal
scepter
receive the rod of equity
and mercy
May the spirit guide you in wisdom and
Grace
that by your service and Ministry
Justice and mercy may be seen in all the
Earth